you've been kind of on the lonely end
certainly on the Republican side of
several votes pertaining to Israel this
is but one example house resolution 771
which is entitled standing with Israel
as it defends itself against the
barbaric War launched by Hamas and other
terrorists and what I'm displaying here
is a tweet from APAC which is the Israel
Lobby saying that you Thomas Massie are
siding with the squad with AOC and
Rashida Talib been Anan Omar and
opposing supporting Israel opposing
condemning Hamas uh you also were the
sole vote against kind of a
symbolic uh recognition of Israel and uh
saying that
anti-Semitism uh or sorry anti- Zionism
equates to anti-Semitism could you just
explain your stance on Israel where
you're coming from and what some of
these you think some of these critics
might be missing about your position
sure that was the first of 19 votes
today we're going to take our 19th
virtue signal vote here in Congress um
but I guess I got off on the wrong foot
early and have been voting consistently
ever since the title of that bill is
wonderful I have no disagreement with
the title of that bill but there are
four or five pages that go after that
title and um that well it's a resolution
the the first you know uh object ction I
have to it was there was inside of that
an
open-ended uh pledge of military support
for Israel okay we've we never declare
Wars anymore the administration just
kind of goes and does it and Congress
keeps funding it but they find the
impera moer for their activity right
there in these resolutions so the
open-ended guarantee of um support for
that war that's contained in the text of
that bill but not the title could have
implied boots on the ground and that may
be the only vote we get to take in
Congress on on whether we're going to do
that or not so number one I don't
support that that notion um number two
there they were in that resolution they
mentioned
Iran okay in the very first resolution
they're already trying to expand the war
and incorporate as much of the Middle
East as they can there's some people
that just can't wait to attack Iran and
they want to use this as the Nexus to
get there so that was in the resolution
a condemnation of Iran I think we should
be trying to constrain the conflict not
to expand it in the first resolution of
support that we passed there were also
um there was a a part of that resolution
wanted uh Stronger sanctions on Iran and
I don't support s sanctions never voted
to sanction a sovereign country in the
11 years that I've been in Congress I
think it leads to war sanctions actually
create crimes only for US citizens
because we're not going to go put
somebody in jail in In Another Country
who trades with Iran what we're
proposing to do when we pass a sanction
is to make a federal law that would
result in the imprisonment of a US
citizen who who trades with Iran and it
hurts the people who are in the country
I think it actually es us closer to war
instead of getting us out of War so that
and there were even more reasons to vote
against that um even though I support
Israel and I condemned Hamas I did that
on my own I may I put out a statement I
support Israel's right to defend itself
and I condemn these attacks but that
wasn't enough one that you took even
more heat for was this one where you you
were the only vote against it and it was
what I guess you would describe as a
virtue signal bill
where um the essentially it's the house
reaffirming the state of Israel's right
to exist and two recognizing uh that
denying Israel's right to exist is a
form of
anti-Semitism um where are you coming
from on these sorts of bills that aren't
even really directly tied to any sort of
military aid or anything like that well
I I recognize Israel's right to exist
okay yeah uh have to preface all of this
stuff with that because people would
imply from a vote that I don't but um
when they passed that I said you're
basically saying that anti-zionism is
anti-Semitism and people argued with me
that that wasn't Zionism you
know that that those words weren't a
proxy for Zionism well what's
interesting is the next week they passed
almost the same resolution and they
replaced Israel's right to exist with
Zion ISM so maybe I'm just giving them
clues for how to write their bills more
directly um because the next resolution
said that anti-zionism is anti-Semitism
and there are hundreds of thousands of
Jewish people who disagree with that
statement in fact Gerald Nadler who's
the most senior member of Congress who's
Jewish went to the floor and gave a five
minute
speech um which is a long speech in the
House of Representatives this isn't the
Senate but he gave a five minute speech
on why that's untrue to say that
anti-zionism is anti-Semitism now there
are a lot of people who are anti-semitic
who are also U against the state of
Israel but you can't equate the two and
I think these uh 19 votes after today
are sort of a it's a it's part of the
war effort for Israel to make it hard
for the for anybody in the United States
to criticize what they're doing like you
every two or three days here in Congress
you have we're taking these votes that a
lot of what's in the resolution is just
obvious and doesn't need to be stated
it's kind of like black lives matter
okay you have to say black lives matter
now they're making they're doing the
equivalent with Israel now Israel
matters and so I agree that Israel
matters but we don't have to take all
these votes and and some of them are
going into campuses and trying to limit
free speech um by withholding Federal
money if you uh if if you allow anti
things that are considered anti-semitic
by the way let's take a second just to
talk about that
word I've been called anti-semitic for
merely not supporting the money that
goes to Israel APAC ran an ad uh they
spent 90,000 th000 in my district
running
ads um implying that I was anti-semitic
and then in a tweet said that I was
anti-semitic for not spending not voting
for The 14.3 billion dollar to go to
Israel even though I've not voted for
forign a to go to anywhere ever do
people do people buy that talking point
of
Apex um the ad was not effective like
when you when they run an ad in my
district that says Thomas Massie was the
Lone Republican to vote against this
resolution and um people are like back
in my district they've I have a history
of being the only vote like that was a
no vote like on the cares act and
explaining why it's a bad vote and then
a couple years later they you know they
find out wow why weren't why didn't
everybody vote the way he did so I've
developed some trust with my
constituents on those loan votes I mean
Chuck Chuck Schumer has accused you of
being being anti-semitic on he's blasted
you on Twitter Ian here's the Tweet he
said rep uh representative Massie you're
a sitting member of Congress uh this is
anti-Semitic disgusting dangerous and
exactly the type of thing I was talking
about in my Senate address take this
down and what he's referring to is the
uh Drake meme where he's uh saying uh
you know no no to American patriotism
yes to uh Zionism con Congress these
days um I mean were you
what was your reaction to having you
know the well someone as prominent as
Chuck Schumer uh accusing you of
anti-Semitism well we ratioed him on
that pretty soundly um I quote tweeted
him and said if only you cared about
half as much about our border as you
care about my tweets and um he he's got
like over 10,000 comments now on on his
tweet to me um it's I mean it's just is
simply not true by the way in the
replies to him you'll find somebody who
pointed out that of of all 535 members
of Congress he rece this cycle he
received more money from pro-israel
Lobby according to ops.org than any
other member of Congress so um it just
it rings Hollow when he says that and
even he's even in disagreement with
Gerald Nadler for instance on equating
anti Zionism to anti-Semitism and I'll
admit memes are not the the most precise
way to convey um a a point but they can
be effective and there you know that
Meme it doesn't imply that there there's
nothing in that Meme that implies those
two things are mutually exclusive and
that wasn't my intent I was just
pointing out that you could you could
it's okay in Congress to be patriotic
for Israel but you can't be patriotic
for America that's considered
nationalism which is American
nationalism is a dirty word and I know
it's loaded and there are a lot of
people that have attached themselves to
it but if you take it the generic sense
it's you know pride in your country so I
use the word patriotism pride pride in
America is is looked down upon right now
it's out of fashion but pride in Israel
is something we have to vote on two or
three times a week now in Congress hey
thanks for watching that clip from our
new show just asking questions you can
watch another clip here or the full
episode here new episodes drop every
week so subscribe to reent TV's YouTube
channel to get notified when that
happens or to the just asking questions
podcast on Apple Spotify or any other
podcaster see you next week